to my beautiful wife you are the calm
and the crazy The Rock in the storm it
is the greatest gift and I love being a
parent with you so multi-marie I can't
wait to come back here with you in 15
years and embarrass you in front of your
friends to my little ones at home Daddy
loves you to the Moon and back
Sophie what up homie
you're my partner in crime you keep me
motivated and inspired every day I
strive to be as cool as you and you got
you got any plans after this
my beautiful wife I love you
so much I could not have done this
without you your support over the last
15 years you've seen us through all of
it the beginning the middle the end and
then back again thank you for everything